thank you for your patience as we have
happened with the
with my name is Sean Cooney I'm the
director of Columbia University of
Faribault and Manuscript library
tonight's lecture see right Mills at
Columbia is the second in our live from
the archive series which highlights
scholarships earnest from the
collections helped by the rare books and
any strip library and turned the series
formed part of a very active published
program hosted by our vml that includes
the book history colloquium series of
gallery talks relating to exhibitions
and the forthcoming Paulo Chris teller
lecture on medieval and renaissance
studies for more information about these
events I encourage you that check out
our website at library.csun.edu writer
for american history with our PML in his
day job he worked to expand and
interpret Columbia's collection of rare
books and manuscripts the documentary
has aspects of American history he's the
author two monographs including more
powerful in dynamite
radicals plutocrats progressives and new
york's year of Anarchy which Noam
Chomsky described as an impressive piece
of work and the New York Times as an
engrossing account with the events of
1914 he's also a in ii-if somewhat
sleepless new father and so with that
many things over to tie we'll introduce
tonight's
thank you welcome everyone smelly spring
that in New York this is a particularly
tricky question because both see right
mills and the Baffler to 5ez
description in not only do they do fire
you get the sense that they actively
rejected and are offended by it as a
member of the Columbia faculty from 1946
until its untimely death in 1962 Mills
was simultaneously a leading sociologist
and a leading critic of academic
sociology he was not quite a Marxist nor
labour intellectual he was not
affiliated with either Soviet socialism
or liberal ancient communism he did not
engage fully with the civil rights
movement and died before the rise of the
new left he was independent intellectual
mid-century he was doing a huge alarm in
Texan who cursed rode a motorcycle and
waged a decades-long fight against his
colleges these delivered lectures and
cowboy boots and leather jackets
described himself as a prophet who came
in from the desert and deprived most
sociology as heavy-duty theoretical
we are pleased to welcome John
summers editor-in-chief of the bathroom
to discuss see right Melissa's years at
Columbia as part of an in-progress
biography that has drawn widely on our
dear Mel's social science collection and
collections from University Archives the
technical problem that we hope to solve
will lead to the playing of
never-before-heard
audio materials
collection someone's that former
lecturer in American Studies here at
Columbia he is the author of an essay
collection that we early on earth and
has edited books of criticism by James
Agee
Dwight MacDonald and Mills as its name
implies the Baffler also is not easy to
pin down an appraisal article in today's
Washington Post is described merely as
of left-wing journal but how many of
those would dedicate an entire issue to
an examination of the fashion industry
Fowler does founded in 1988 as a
magazine of article criticism that has
been variously described as a pump
literary magazine and a printed magazine
of unconstructive thinking summers who
took the editorship in 2011 and
afternoon a new fluorescence for the
journal which features regular
commentary from such leading
intellectuals as Thomas Frank Rick
roasting Nicholson Baker Barbara
Ehrenreich Susan Faludi
graver the best way to get a sense of
the journal other than subscribed it to
it which everyone should do might be to
stand some recent blog posts and
articles which includes an expose on the
Ferguson police scandal headline a cat
photo approach to history a piece on
hipster fashion entitled the revolution
will probably wear mom jeans noise from
know Harris and essay on cable news
while I think piece on sadomasochism and
economic crisis is entitled Fifty Shades
of late capitalism this is must be
journalism and despite or maybe because
of the gloss and the irony it speaks
directly to one of Milton's most
wrenching observations that quote in a
world of widely communicated nonsense
and statement of fact is a very nice
very well said although subjects come up
and we can just talk about all of them
at once but today I'd like to first
check that you can hear me okay and ii
assure you that i will be focused see
right mills
columbia there's anybody before i start
because there'll be some hard words
being spoken today mostly in quotation
does anybody here in the room no new
robert merton paul lazarsfeld or see
right mills yes you run a committee
which department in the sociology
department yes you were i see you run a
committee and harriet Zuckerman is here
with us tonight
so you qualify anyone else paul
lazarsfeld robert merton or mills okay
so i think i have the field the power
elite hooked me I read that book the
third installment of see right Mills is
great trilogy of American civilization
sometime during the Clinton
administration just after as you will
recall the end of history the book
tapped a vein in me and that's been
flowing for longer than I care to
remember
like other history graduate students in
the 90s I'd been reading around in that
revival of pragmatism literature that
blew through the postmodern Academy with
a post Cold War tailwind and I kept
noticing some surprise that Mills his
name kept coming up there I learned soon
though that before he turned himself
into a best-selling popular author he'd
written his dissertation on John Dewey
William James and Charles purse the
original pragmatists he called them his
Godfather's Mills his dissertation which
was never published in his lifetime was
all but impenetrable to me but such was
its importance in the 50s that had mu it
had moved like zombies dot in the
underground intellectual culture I took
his early engagement with pragmatism as
my own point of departure and jumped in
my graduate advisor at the University of
Rochester had written a masterpiece of
intellectual biography on John Dewey and
because graduate school there and
everywhere else is about mirroring your
betters I knew I could win his support I
would write an intellectual history of
pragmatism in Searight Mills as social
thought I would trace the characteristic
qualities of the pragmatic attitude from
his early highly technical studies in
the sociology of knowledge to his
colorful career at Columbia and down to
his last stand in Havana just as Hegel
was famously said to have left a
permanent deposit and John Dewey's
thought I would show how to ease
pragmatism left a permanent deposit in
Mills is and by showing the fundamental
consistency underlying his intellectual
personal
I could honor a directive from the
rochester history departments patron
saint of broken links and tragic notions
christopher lash who had beckoned young
historians like myself to reconstruct
traditions of independent thought and
who had died the year before I arrived
in Rochester and if I had stuck to that
plan it's possible that I would be
standing before you today as a tenured
professor of intellectual history a
salaried academic professional and good
standing rather than an ex academic an
interloper and a critic hanging on by
the seat of my pants what happened was I
read the power elite and it floored all
of my abstractions by subverting my
early deference to expertise much later
I found in the Special Collections
upstairs I never published manuscript by
Moses longtime colleague historian
Richard Hofstadter it was a response to
the power elite that summed up my own
feelings at the time and I'm going to
quote the site of an American academic
trying courageously in these times of
danger and complacency to confront the
larger issues of the world from a
notably rebellious point of view is in
itself a thing to command attention and
respect no other American writer has
attempted in recent years to analyze in
a fundamental way the exercise of power
and Mills presents us with a distinctive
phenomenon the sociologist with a style
the phenomenon we have not seen since
the days of Thorstein Veblen right on I
thought a distinctive phenomenon that's
what I would take as my subject I
couldn't write anymore a narrow gauged
intellectual history I had to know all
about the kind of person who would brave
such a book how he had come by his
Promethean aspirations how I'd managed
to double his work in his life why he
had died so young and what lay behind
the passion and the drive that were so
evident in all his work writing a proper
biography now intrigued me that had also
made sense on the subjects own terms one
of the first things I realized was that
most of the thinkers and writers whom I
admired never split their work from
their lives said Mills once writing to
his imaginary friend tovarich
it was a choice of how to
live as well as a choice of career for
whether he knows it or not the
intellectual workman forms his own self
as he works toward the perfection of his
craft and so I came early to the
conviction that to realize my own
potentialities and opportunities says
Mills I had to construct a character
somehow I realized that I must learn to
use my life experience in my
intellectual work continually to
interpret it and to use it following
along I set out to write a biography of
the character that Charles Wright and
Mills created from his life experience
starting in the 1930s when during high
school in Dallas he began keeping his
journal and winding up in the 60s when
his writing fermented mass unrest in
every industrial country in the world I
came to see Mills as an American version
of a wider phenomenon a spiritual
descendent of stem dolls Julian Sorelle
true gain devs Bazarov and Jack London's
Martin Eden when in a long line of new
men born into the provinces of the new
masked societies sons without fathers
non-party revolutionists they were
intellectuals as well as actors roles
between which they acknowledged no need
to choose and Mills in fact and indeed
coined the now ubiquitous term public
intellectual in 1958
my favorite early find among the
documentary record was a CIA report
called Restless youth from 1968 six
years after Mills's death the report
picked out Herbert Marcuse a friend's
fennan and Mills as the three most
influential intellectuals in the world
and everything else I've learned since
then has proven that at least this one
time the CIA got it right so I began my
research by spending time in Special
Collections like the one upstairs
digging like a junkyard dog through
every pertinent scrap of paper I could
find and by talking with every person
who knew him I set out to write an
expansive unstinting and reliable
biography of the man on his own terms
every chapter would contain portions of
biography criticism and history mixing
in a style that describes Mills as
person
and professional growth evaluates his
writing his lecturing and his teaching
and locates the story in relation to the
characters settings institutions and
events through which he moved the
challenge I still see it is lies in
marrying a really extraordinary range of
personal and subjective judgments about
Mills to the rigor and respect for facts
of scholarship one reason then I'm here
with you today is to share with you some
findings from the collections at
Columbia which was on the face of it and
as you'll soon hear a starkly ambivalent
setting for his life experience some
people on the campus and those was a
culture hero to most of the others
including his senior colleagues in
sociology paul lazarsfeld and robert
merton he was an embarrassment sociology
students and faculty whom I interviewed
all told me his name was a dead letter
in the department as early as 1964 he
was nevertheless an important figure in
the Columbia community from 1945 when he
first came to campus until his death in
1962 and too much of the independent
literate public in New York he virtually
defined the university's cultural and
political aspirations to the new left
Mills is standing at Columbia was a
matter of political importance as
Apocrypha circulated about his academic
career long after his death in the
coming crisis of Western sociology for
example Alvin Gould nur asserted that
Mills had never made it to a full
professor Columbia not true he was
promoted in 1956 a German translator of
Mills is textbook character and social
structure claimed that he had lost his
professorship and the McCarthy purges
not true he was not touched by this by
that time but then a Yugoslavian Journal
of social science repeated the error and
on and on it went from the 60s the most
interesting rumor that I found was that
and picked up from some college students
was that paul lazarsfeld and robert
burton had conspired to murder mills
in the basement of the hundred and
sixteenth Street subway station I've
been at this for a long time but I have
not found any evidence as an attempted
murder but I would like to take you
through briefly three standout moments
in Mills career at Columbia the first
has to do with his unlikely hiring to
direct a field study in Decatur Illinois
on behalf of the Bureau of applied
Social Research one day in 1945 excuse
me in January of 1945 Robert Merton
surprised Mills with a telephone call
would he come up from the University of
Maryland where he was currently teaching
and pay a visit to the bureau well so
far as professional interests went
Merton and Mills had a lot more in
common with one another than either man
shared with paul lazarsfeld for several
years beforehand mills and Merton had
engaged in a vigorous correspondence
about the sociology of knowledge
crossing Penn's over matters highly
technical but agreeing wholeheartedly
about the need to develop in the United
States what had been a European
preoccupation Merton having studied with
Talcott Parsons came to the field after
reading Emile Durkheim Mills
having studied with Chicago trained
sociologists at the University of Texas
came to it from Dooley and particular
from George Meade for the theoretical
acuity of their early essays in this
emerging field Merton and Mills were
widely considered two of the most
promising young sociologists in the
country at this time there was another
more personal affinity unlike Lazar
Stowe who came from a politically
prominent highly educated family in
Austria Merton and Mills were more or
less on their own Merton was born in
Philadelphia to immigrant parents his
father had worked as a carpenter and a
storekeeper and he had a temple attended
Temple University of scholarship after
graduate school at Harvard and after a
brief tenure at Tulane University he
joined Columbia at the age of 31 already
considered a leader in the field Mills
was born in Waco Texas into a
middle-class home his father was a
traveling salesman without much of a
tradition of cultural aspiration
achievement when he graduated from high
school in Dallas his father sent him to
military school he transferred to Texas
the next year like Mills
excuse me like Merton Mills proved
himself in the state school caught the
attention of older men in graduate
school and looked upon the expanding
field of sociology as a way up and out
such were the expectations laid up
around Mills the sociology department at
Maryland gave him his first job in 1941
as an associate professor allowing him
to leave over the assistant rank
completely this was before he had
finished his dissertation on one Friday
night in January the end of 1945 Lazar
spelled Merton and Mills three mend his
combined work with transform American
sociology and virtually define columbia
sociology met in manhattan for a seven
hour conversation jag over a big meal in
an expensive restaurant the conversation
passed over the assignment to go to
Decatur Illinois and study public
opinion they talked about the moral
problems involved with commercial
research now and then several young
women from Smith and Vassar but had been
invited to the table by Lazarus fell to
seduce Mills into joining the team
spoken sugary voices and after the women
departed glasses felt set forth the
terms Mills was have was to have the
title of research associate at the
Bureau of applied Social Research he was
to go to Decatur Illinois in the summer
and direct the opinion study he could
publish under his own name and if all
went well he might expect to join the
sociology faculty at Columbia on a
permanent basis Mills reported the
evening and a starry-eyed letter to his
parents after they'd laid out the job
and said well that's it we want you will
you come
I said holding myself in bursting with
joy at the whole idea Christ I'd go for
food and shelter anyway I kept my face
in mobile and I said for how much they
wouldn't say but replied you know what
you're worth naman to waste little
Charlie said very quietly I won't charge
you that much but I could think I
couldn't think of it in terms less than
forty five hundred immediately the guy
said and your beginning salary will be
five
5,000 to which the appropriate reply was
that's closer to what I'm worth and
everybody laughed and felt good On
January 26th the next week having
secured a leave of absence from Maryland
Mills wrote allows us not to accept the
offer each week that spring he rode the
train from Washington to Manhattan spent
one day at the bureau feeling his way
around his offices on 59th and Amsterdam
getting to know his colleagues learning
about the campus meanwhile on campus a
huge fight was raging those opposed to
the hiring of mills at Columbia feared
that laser spot and Merton were using
him to drive the bureau closer to the
University and it's plentiful resources
in this they were correct
at the end of May as Mills set out for
Decatur the bureau signed its first
formal agreement with the university so
Mills enters basically through the back
door and there's immediate suspicion of
his motives and his suspicions of Lazar
stalled in Merton and their motives and
that's important for the story later
that's the first moment that's the point
of that's the point of entry the second
moment which has never been reported as
far as I know by anybody comes in 1956
in 1957 when Mills tried to block Daniel
Bell from coming on to the sociology
faculty there were personal as well as
professional reasons behind this and I
found all the evidence for it or the
evidence that gave me the sense that I
knew what had happened over at the
Columbiana archive in the papers of
David Truman and the four Bell died I
had the pleasure of showing him what I
found and he was utterly shocked well he
said he was shocked he was a wily guy so
let me give you a little bit of
background about sociology and in the
fifties it's one Bo faculty here who
were giving courses in sociology drew
from no fewer than five different
administrative units in addition to
Columbia College and the Graduate School
there was the school of Jenner
studies there was Barnard College and it
was the bureau Lazar spelled who ran the
bureau supposed that a greater number of
sociologists encircled Morningside
Heights in the 50s than the total number
of sociologists at all French and
British universities combined and Mills
thought himself to be virtually alone a
part of the reason for this was the
intricate status hierarchy that was
governing governing sociology at this
time it was a strictly bureaucratic
separation of roles responsibilities and
rewards these five administrative units
basically shaped themselves into an
oligarchic pyramid with the bureau
occupying the bottom where most of the
women worked by the way general studies
Barnard into college filling out the
middle and with the graduate faculty
lording over the whole a Mills was a
member of the college and he had his
offices in Hamilton Hall and he had to
teach the contemporary civilization
course to freshmen and sophomores
Lazarus Foden Merton members of the
Graduate School had their officers
offices and Fairweather Hall and as far
as I've been able to tell maybe I'll be
corrected never taught any undergraduate
courses at all as a member of the
college Mills had no political rights
over hiring decisions this is the key
point of reproduction of course in the
profession now the full sociology
faculty can convene once a month in
meetings that Mills had the right to
attend formally he held the right to
teach graduate students as well
sociology courses at Columbia were
apportioned under five levels of
hierarchy the lowest three levels were
reserved for the undergraduates the
highest level reserves were reserved for
the graduate students and level four
courses were open to graduate students
as well as to juniors and seniors in the
College on the few occasions that Nils
taught one of these 400 level courses he
attracted stray graduate students who
found in his writings as who found his
writing to stimulating and as
sophisticated as anything going in their
graduate professors and yet mills gave
nobody the impression that he was
interested in graduate students all the
influence that he collected was
concentrated in the College among the
undergraduates there in fact he was the
departmental representative
for sociology the closest thing to a
department chair reporting to the Dean
of the college
now while Mills cultivated a stable of
undergraduate apprentices in and around
the college Lazar so Dan Burton formed a
powerhouse of theory in the Graduate
School now Lazarus felt was a squat and
cigar-chomping loud talking refugee and
Merton was an elegant polished ironical
son of South Philadelphia they made an
unlikely pair on the matter of Mills
though they formed a social and
methodological alliance that immediately
sent a book like the causes of World War
three just Mill's his best-selling
anti-war book and to her pamphlet in
1958 straight to the dustbin either
Merton or Lazarus felt held the title of
executive officer of the graduate
department ever since 1949
Malone and together they offered the
completest most sophisticated most
professional training in the history of
American sociology the golden rung on
the ladder from college to career thanks
to Merton and Lazarus felt the very best
students from the New York metropolitan
area and elsewhere came to Columbia for
their associati doctorates whereupon
they graduated into white-collar jobs
and advertising agencies foundations
research institutes and other
universities the hiring of professional
sociologists part of the massive
post-war boom higher education didn't
slow down for 20 years and the duo spent
most of this time the catbird seat of
professional resources to give you an
example in the late 50s than this moment
is happening of Mills is marginalization
from American sociology consider the 25
papers that were delivered in at the
1957 conventions of the American
sociology Society the largest ever as
the title suggested it was to be
regarded as the most comprehensive
introduction to the disciplines
proliferating specialties and growing
methodological self-consciousness
Talcott Parsons contributed to this book
chapter 1 general theory in sociology
Lazarus vogue contributed Chapter two
problems in methodology
merton wrote the introduction and
co-edited the volume sociology today
sold 10,000 copies in the first two
months Mills wasn't mentioned not even
in the footnotes so that's the
background Mills comes into the college
by the back door and then he's done a
college he's on Columbia College
marginalized from the main action and
with no political rights so as long as
this institutional division of
reputation and responsibility was in
place the two sides could keep
themselves but could hold one another at
a reasonable distance Mills would sneer
at the specialists at Merton and Lazar
spelled were producing in fair weather
Lazarus Oda and Merton condescended to
him in Hamilton but still it was it was
it was quite evident to partisans on
both sides what was happening
Mills at some point 5859 became friendly
with Carlos Fuentes and I interviewed
Fuentes about their relationship Mills
was Kiefer stablishing Quintus and the
North American market he told me and he
said that he was once walking with Mills
on campus here when Lazarus Feld came
into sight and abruptly turned around
and walked sharply in another direction
20 said there was a cloud of hatred
against Mills on that campus I saw it
with my own eyes the the problem came in
1957 the problem that eventually ended
Mills is I think functional relationship
with Columbia much earlier than is often
assumed came in the autumn of 1957 when
Mills sent back word that he'd have to
stay in Austria where his wife was
divorcing him from the inside of a
psychiatric facility she believed me a
whole nother story and was going to be
missing classes at the last minute in
fact three replacement teachers had to
be hired to take over his Columbia
College courses somebody also had to
take over his duties as the Columbia as
the college's
ecology representative and Lazarus felt
frankly used the occasion to move
against him saying that he believed that
Mills in relaying the story of his
wife's illness was trying to trick the
department into allowing him to extend
his stay in Europe
Lazarus felt summarily fired him from
his post as representative to the
College with mertens backing he proposed
to hire another sociologist to bring
some order to the department lots of
thought says in an oral history
interview on file here on campus we just
didn't want to have anything to do with
him anymore he was by any liberal
standards academically unacceptable
acceptable Lazar thought in fact wanted
to fire him outright Mills as was his
temperament erupted in a fit of
exasperated indignation at what he
called these stupid bastards in
sociology at Columbia he wrote to the
Dean of the college was at that time
Lawrence Chamberlain to convey his
displeasure when he wrote to Lewis Kosar
to recruit him as an envoy asking him
for the names of sociologists to offer
up as alternatives until now I have not
really fought these people in American
sociology he said which wasn't true I've
ignored them and done my own work but
now they've been fooling around behind
the scenes and now I declare war I'm
going to expose their essential
bankruptcy he did manage to quell
sentiment for a laser sword and mertens
first choice for the appointment but by
the time Cade returned to campus from
Austria they really had something
interesting in mind they were
brandishing the name of the one man they
knew he could never abide Daniel Bell
now there's a whole backstory to the
Bell story that I don't know we don't
have time to get into but they were
Mills and Bell before he'll hear the
audio then it'll become more apparent
but Bell told me that when the when when
this decision was happening he went to
Mills apartment to ask to sound out his
position on the matter whether he would
be opposing or not that he said that he
he was he was coy but as soon as Bell
departed actually the next day we were
able to date it
Mills wrote to Dean Chamberlain to say
didn't want paul lazarsfeld to exercise
the right of hiring in the college and
he damn sure didn't want Daniel Bell as
a colleague so at this point Bell a
turbulent agreed to hear the opinion of
an ad hoc committee to break the
stalemate on the committee was David
Truman the professor of government it
was the chair also on the committee was
Richard Hofstadter
Charles Frankel and glasersfeld and
Mills the procedure was straightforward
Lazarus voted mills were to put forward
their first choices the committee would
then debate the choices and then it
would file a report to Chamberlain in
whose hands the decision would rest
Lazarus felt as expected and nominated
Daniel Bell a Mills I know this is
inside baseball but bear with me
Mills nominated Morrill burger was at
that time an assistant professor of
sociology at Princeton University and a
close friend of Daniel bells Bell was
absolutely shocked when I told him that
Nelse had put up his friend against him
but the the decision was it effectively
made on in May of 1958 a couple of
months later when Bell took the took the
platform at a colloquium similar to this
environment and and tried to annihilate
the power elite in a talk where Merton
and hazard Feld sat in the back and
clapped while Nils was not invited this
if you're a reader of Daniel bells and
you know his book the end of ideology
the the talk that he gave the Columbia
ended up in that book and and in fact
was a very important moment for Bell
three days after bells performance
David Truman Hofstadter and Franco all
filed a report with Chamberlain the
feeling of the committee majority is
that mr. bell would be an addition of
major importance to the college and the
university and that it would be a
serious mistake not to bring him to
Columbia this is the report that I found
on file at Columbia colombiano room
the quality and range of his published
work is most impressive and we feel that
his mind and personality are of a sort
ideally fitted to the needs and the best
traditions of teaching in Columbia
College the committee report regretted
to note that one of the members had
refused to yield we have discussed the
obvious disadvantages stemming from the
appointment of a man not agreeable to
the other senior sociologists in the
college and we've been forced to the
conclusion that when we are faced in our
judgment by a choice between securing
the services of a first-rate man and
promoting Congeniality within the
department our responsibilities to the
College in to the University obligate us
to place considerations of intellectual
quality first Dean Chamberlain
telephoned Mills ten days later to say
that he had decided to accept the
committee's recommendations Chamberlain
said Wright has been most reasonable in
a letter to Lazarus Feldman
he continues to believe that Daniel Bell
is not the best man available but in his
own words he shouldn't stand in the way
of the report because it represents a
carefully considered analysis of the
problems functionally speaking that was
the end of Mills career Columbia his
reputation never covered recovered among
his colleagues and he stayed away over
the next two and a half years as
consistently as you could traveling he
was also very sick and not showing up
for classes and in 1959 he published as
promised the sociological imagination
which was a direct attack on Lazarus
Feld and a sneaky attack on Merton
there's a hidden reference to Robert
Merton in one of the chapters and the
the story which began in 1945 with this
great seven hour talking jag and dinner
and with great promise ended with all
three men very famous and Mills on the
outs so the deaths so there's two
moments that kind of framed the story
the third moment and again I'm
emphasizing things that I've discovered
in the research and this is the this was
the best one came after Mills his death
few weeks this was on April 16 1962 in
Harkness theatre there was a
commemorative meeting attended by about
150 people who came to mourn sort of
Mills as death I think only Nils could
have been made the subject of such a
contentious affair the sociology
department now as you'll hear in a
moment sponsored the meeting but Merton
and Lazarus felt specifically declined
to attend in the Columbia oral history a
few months later allows us felt called
Mills a man of great gifts and said he
admired his erudition but their long
feud had taken an irreversible toll the
sociological imagination he said it
seemed to him as a work of ruthless
egotism in fact Lazarus felt neither
attended the commemorative meeting nor
wrote Mills his widow eros lava a
condolence letter he specifically
refused to write her a condolence letter
he says I absolutely refused even after
his death to had anything to do with him
that is to say I never regretted
whatever harm I might have done you see
I had the absolutely opposite feeling
not only did I not regret nor did I not
feel that it would be embarrassing now
that he would now that he would know all
what I think about him but I made it an
external point not to take the slightest
notice of whether he was dead or not
Mills is a one-time best friend and and
a more reasonable former colleague
Richard Hofstadter
sent a short and dignified note to the
affair and another Columbia professor
Charles Franco spoke well as did Walter
clink and Walter and William Tabor
former students and research assistants
who described Mills as the kind of
teacher who changed lives and the person
who presided over this affair was of
course Daniel Bell so we're going to
hear eight minutes of the opening of the
commemorative meeting of 1962 and my la
knowledge this is the first time that
anybody's it's been played publicly for
sure
a solemn occasion I don't think right
those wouldn't want that that config
that this is not really think the royal
meeting or a eulogy meeting this is
primarily the best word we could find a
commemorative meeting in the schedule
belt Bob which is sponsored by the
Columbia College tell Scott Department
one of its comings if that was hard to
begin a meeting of this kind of I think
it will miss them but we're going to try
to do is to have simply short statements
that many speeches reminiscences if you
will comments recollections by various
individuals who one way or another
worked with dried mills we have comes
birth who was learning teaches and when
we collaborated on the studies of mocs
favor Rob that's within
best in heritage in Columbia we brought
them to Columbia Charles Franklin who
ran a seminar for 70 years which Lynn
Louis Kozar one of the items of dissent
that professor of sociology Brandeis and
magazine with which girls collaborators
for a number of years some former
students and junior colleagues such as
what to think and we would work with
Mills and in one way or another would
want to add some recollections back in
Mills came to Columbia 1945 and except
for a short period of time University of
Maryland spent almost an entire academic
life at Columbia he was a man who is any
of you had any contact in
rather extraordinary individual which
meant to drive
I find myself rather next to feelings
were talking about Mills because in some
way I my own acquaintance with him goes
back about 20 years
I suspect except for so I good he was a
student at Texas texting another my own
relations with Mills probably longer
than those people without here that's
been a mixed speculations and I like to
think of Mills in terms of the kind of
birth he was in terms about the
agreements and disagreements that I've
had with him as a way of understanding
it was a person our first met right
Mills used to come Charles at the time
of Charlie Wright became something can
will formalize as a later name when he
was graduated into Texas a graduate
student was concen and I at that time
was the magic editor of a small weekly
think positive leader I've read some
articles of Mills in the journals and I
thought they were very big risks and
quite interesting and quite out of
ordinary
I wrote to him and said would you like
to lose in writing for the new Liam and
he breathed and beginning about 1942 I
think the first writing that right Mills
ever did outside of the first academic
articles was for the new leader he went
about 1942 at the University of Maryland
which himself was a included choice I
suppose
and yet in some of these accidental
concatenations of academic
roots it was a meeting ground for what
were people who had a spectacular career
since because one became very proud at
that time with dick Hofstadter with his
teaching environment at the time with
Frank Reidel who would come down there
and with number of other young
historians and they represent that their
rather vigorous group of people at the
University of Maryland there
three or four years and subsequently
then went elsewhere Hofstadter them
bills coming up to Colombia Fidel funny
going on to Harvick and some of the
others going elsewhere I think one went
to a birthday when the other story
escapes me it's the time when he was at
Maryland began doing quite a bit of
writing as I say he become from
trimmings the new leader and began
writing the journal so I think he can't
the attention of the women who have a
rather visual privacy vigorous young
talent particularly talent which is
radical have certain Drive and
personality and live I think began to
see in bills a potential person at
Columbia one of the things which I can
perhaps without a need since his old
father passed talk about now is the fact
that certain degree of anger I had
impersonally a professor at a time
because then said the mills after he
first met what do you want to write a
new leader that's not the kind of max
the other wife for what happened to
Republic
and introduced right close to the others
the Republic will have their
headquarters in New York at the time and
Healdsburg antibody can blue in color so
I got some private contract letters from
him saying well you know you understand
they pay $75 an article and besides
which you know would you pay at least I
don't know if I really agree with you
anyway I'm glad you gave me a chance to
buy for the leader but and this when
Thomas Piketty spec for 30 years knows
not out cars by instilling used to come
up to New York particularly when with
his first job I don't think was actually
at Kobe Cod there's a very involved
instead of negotiation to put occurred
the bureau he was working for the bureau
apply social search the in 1945 when
coming up to New York and staying with
me of my place we need to get into a
long argument assemblage with
independent I suspect another structural
disagreements but one of the things that
always comes through in that this
extraordinary drive of the man because
these the drawings becomes the key word
and looking through some impetus last
night then we just asked with not buying
anybody sense of privacy read it was
necessary it seems to me so much of the
man himself this is a this have been
some correspondence about a project
which is engaged already in february 7
1945 intellectuals and he was at that
time trying to deal with runs of various
magazines and trying to argue that one
could identify key electric currents to
the articles in magazines he was going
to have here as assess a 50-year project
was rather typical the man who says you
see in the end about fifty years from
now we might very well expand to the
size garden left coming intellectuals
political literary magazines as well as
several natural movements and this was
his image of time he was going to think
about a 50th period he wasn't just going
to doing a little thinking of studying
the bags
built into a washed-out project and then
the nd has a scroll footnote handwritten
footnote which has 10:00 p.m. he says
the work plans just phone wanted to do a
six-week study starting tomorrow the
effects of different industry definitely
types of six times via plane with God
sort of fortune
so if what's another journal leaves
that's my business one article that he
said the other side after the study I
would have to appear before the Senate
committee as expert in sociology of
business and then he writes ladies and
gentlemen introducing these sociologists
we have business family in America onion
patch 40 was Missy and 40 blossom land
there's a lot more to that but the we
had more time we would I would talk to
you a little bit more about Robert Lind
his on another clip he spent 22 minutes
during this commemorative service
denouncing Mills and at one point you
can hear it
Hans girth and Belle mentions was Mills
is former teacher
it was continent who had flown in for
the service into Jack's and tries to
rush to podium at at Lind be kind of
this anger so Mills is the only person
that I've come across so far this was
denounced at his own funeral and I think
I'll just end there thank you very much
anybody want to chat with Lynne I mean
Robert Lind is an interesting figure
he's not much mentioned anymore
and as far as I know there isn't a
biography or a major study of his work
but he was very important to ologist and
he had come to was a former Presbyterian
minister who had kind of drifted into
sociology and Lind felt that Mills had
misappropriated some funds in the
department and he didn't like Mills as
style of haggling for raises they
defended his what he called his
Midwestern sensibility and but I think
more to the point he also really
disliked the power elite he thought that
the book was even he said so he wrote
long critique of it in the nation and I
thought it's a strange relationship
because the conceptions of power are not
exactly antithetical they're actually
very closely aligned Mills and and
inland there's also some sense that Lind
had felt mistreated in the department
and by the time Mills came along as the
hotshot young sociologist who
outstripped him and became more well
known and began to occupy a place in the
culture that Lind had briefed briefly
entertained in the 30s that he became
bitter but those kind of things have to
be asserted with a lot of evidence but
otherwise it's not entirely clear to me
why Lind felt that he needed to denounce
Mills but at some point it'll be this
recording I hope will be published and
you can hear for yourself
in what they know how to cast it it was
because it was late I just went it just
was interesting that this is the sense
that bill came out and the second
question was was he very popular sounds
like he was yes yes yeah as as time
mentioned he dressed in a flamboyant way
and he was a very clear and forceful
lecturer which is actually his Bell told
me he was a very good lecturer he held
the students attention the fact that he
was also a figure outside the university
was an additional point in his favor so
he was quite popular but but there's a
anecdote that I heard Mills at a party
where a bunch of sociology graduate
students are and this is in the late 50s
and he's fairly well known at this time
and he's sitting in the corner and the
students are filing past and there he's
saying you know what are you studying
and they're saying what they're studying
into every single person he says why so
there was a great divergence with
graduate students which was a shame
well they officer died I believe was
1972 and long before I came on the scene
doing interviews but I did interview his
widow and it's not clear that they did
have clear falling-out hofstadter wasn't
the type to have a lot of fallings out
he but when the Cuba book was published
in 1960 Mills went to Havana interviewed
Fidel Castro and wrote a book about it
off center was was just short of
appalled at the swerve that he had taken
toward well toward you know revolution
revolutionary nationalism so that the
political differences were very sharp by
that time and you know by the end of the
60s Hofstadter himself is feeling quite
alienated and out of sorts as Mills his
followers changed a culture from within
and the great moment is the commencement
address that Hofstadter gave in 1968
which i think is on your mind as an
important point in Columbia's history
Frank Fidel who's mentioned earlier and
excuse me knows Kenneth stampp actually
one of the historians that Mills
befriended it Maryland I was walking
with Richard Hofstadter and in front of
the library after the 68 rebellion or
protest I don't know what the official
term is here and stamp set the
Hofstetter
oh you know Charlie would have been in
his element and Hostetter apparently
took the opposite view and said no no on
the contrary he would have been appalled
at the desecration of the campus and
that's an interesting thing to discuss
or to think about their arguments on
both sides
I've not I don't I've not come across
any that no but I had been able to place
Allen Ginsberg and Mills at Norman
Mailer's famous party where he
stabbed his wife and apparently Ginsburg
you know was aware of Mills feud with
Columbia sociology and was asking him
how he was handling you know these guys
right then they they left the party
together in the elevator that's the best
I've got I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm an
editor and a biographer which means I'm
a gossip so if I had more I would give
it to you yeah absolutely
in fact you know one of the formulations
I'm trying to advance this but you know
military school was where he discovered
society later at Texas is where he
discovered sociology and he discovered
society in a very brutal form he was yet
a very terrible incident have happened
halfway through his time at Texas A&M
this is 1934 he was involved with the
wrestling match in which he broke
somebody's arm and there was thought on
campus that he had maybe done it on
purpose and and there was some thought
from Mills his own journals that he was
pretty upset at the beatings that he had
been getting from the upperclassmen
because this was a did this is a pretty
harsh environment and he had you know he
had suffered beatings and and and then
the incident happened in the spring then
of 1935 the campus the cadets all
ostracized him no one spoke to him for
the entire semester socially he was a
nonentity
he was ostracism is the kind of textbook
definition of what happened to him and
he really had a nervous collapse after
that and always discussed it later as a
point of formation and and then went to
Texas which was at the time a sissy
school according to the cadets and and
and then tried to recover some of the
experience and formulate his own
sociology so it was an entirely negative
experience and he protests by writing
letters to the editor there's a there's
a paper trail
yes
the net result but what does that mean
yeah well bail was on the faculty well
the department was not on their left or
the right
it was occupying of scientific
professionally neutral position that's
that's what the writings very clearly
say I mean if you take Robert Merton for
example and maybe we can talk about this
Merton was a beautiful stylist and a
beautiful writer but was in his in his
writings but clearly against style and
rhetoric he thought that sociology was a
science and would be developing into a
science they all did they established
deleting cutting edges sociology in the
fifties that was the position that they
were left and but that they were neutral
so the question that's visit the terms
of the discussion so I don't think it
they were right or left or in the
department I mean Bell was Bell left I
think after 68 after the after the and
went to Harvard
and I'm like we sure exactly how to
answer the question but that's what
happened well he was left wing he was
probably the most influential left wing
American intellectual or 20th century
but that's but his conception of
sociology did not imply any particular
political position yeah it's tricky but
it's actually true that the discussion
is not over politics the discussion is
how to go about sociology Mills the
initial draft for Mills his famous book
the sociological imagination was called
social science as a way of life and I
read to you the discussion about using
your life experiences in your work and
incorporating them that was totally an
asthma to Merton Ruth Hauser felt it was
not allowed it was disreputable to do
that sort of thing
certainly when I had two corners died
and that feeling that came about
continued for at least 15 years
well you said you had a feeling it was
maybe but that doesn't know it was my
fieldwork and it was the general view
last ones no I think Mills was
responsible work except because he named
Belle in his letter to the new Latin but
why do people wasn't just that later on
when both down in one hand issued a
report on the family you know that was
reported by them to the left of every
action report now we might see it
differently but that but certainly do
know they'll did represent a right wing
position in the sixties and seventies I
can't speak terrible we'll take one last
question and then there's education
and I was very startled when I read his
phrase the church will grow by and where
he started to have a very negative sort
of technology how much well the cheerful
robot first appears I don't think it's
much to do with technology as such but
it appears in white-collar first and and
the book is you know is a fairly
devastating carries a fairly devastating
hypothesis that the trouble is we can't
come to a collective self-consciousness
that that that's the thesis of the book
and you know the cheerful robot is a is
a kind of residue of what we would now
think of as a happiness industry I mean
what's more common in American society
than they urged to smile and to be happy
and I mean there was a undercurrent of
criticism I mentioned the underground
culture of the 50s the beats were
involved with this but it came from many
different directions trying to undermine
this core proposition of the post-war
Americans what Mills called the American
celebration
the cheerful robot is the kind of
character ideal type of the American
triumphal celebration
fully fleshed out that there was some
discomfort they
the military yep and their develop their
technology it seemed no I think and I
know we want to conclude but I mean what
I presented today is the is the starkest
most you know this polarity it's
possible Mills was Mills was and they
had this in common with Merton but very
sophisticated sociological theorist and
one of the things that leads him to the
cultural to the triple robot is this
idea of what rationality without reason
which was something that Karl Mannheim
had put on the map for American
intellectuals and Bell and Lagerfeld and
Merton and Mills they all proceeded from
Carlmont on ultimately it's a venerian
critique so it's not so much technology
it's more the relation of Technology and
culture as framed it as an ideological
problem I'm happy to continue to talk at
the reception